[Music]
and flex with precaution news so your
announcer voice hello every strong one
oh that's a big one I'm a strong boy
that is a big one I'm a strong boy too
you are I'm a weak [ __ ]
it's my kink actually yeah this is
submitted by fists of fury oh yeah gross
new movie just came out with Jackie Chan
what is it warrior all the show no
Jackie Chan's not in it it's it's Bruce
Lee's it's Bruce Lee script
yeah me and Joe went to the premiere
that [ __ ] was something there was a new
movie like a year ago or something that
they didn't approve of the family
improvement on the unauthorized Oh cuz
keys he got an invite to some [ __ ]
there's a permanent today and then like
his sisters or his sister sister is
gonna that's probably the same show that
means Osaka's his neither he was behind
or no his daughter was buying different
yes oh it's a family member Shannon Lee
yeah and she gave like a speech before
her she's nice
mm-hm so FAFSA we all know FAFSA getting
that cash money flow responded to a
tweet of a teen flexing online and now
everyone is paranoid what's fast huh
it's a financial aid government grants
for students event I used to get that
stands for Free Application for Federal
Student Aid yeah you guys again
everybody can you believe it I thought
that was a loan for like two years
straight that's why I kept straight A's
cuz I thought I'm gonna have to pay it
back I don't know if I consider you guys
lucky for that or not cuz I was at that
end where I applied for it well my
parents are right at that boundary line
where they make enough for where I can't
get it well you're lucky because you
came from a home no but then we don't
make enough to send me through those
kind of colleges well I mean the middle
class is [ __ ] right that's the worst
yeah but it's like the attacks of the
highest percentage we're gonna [ __ ] yeah
so this seven
your old high school senior named
Lizbeth blue bus she shared a video of
her during prom she captioned it
hashtag prom to caming that's a prom
dress
already no I had to step out oh my
goodness that looks like a like a Las
Vegas showgirl dress beautiful dress so
this is a video I bet you by the time we
have kids that go to prom they're just
gonna be wearing pasties that's gonna be
the style nipple tassels the other way
where it's like 1950 yeah please please
[Music]
some crazy video for prom javis be an
editor this is why she didn't get FAFSA
so fast is like hey [ __ ] you food I
don't understand why fast head is not
cool she wanted like a legit prom video
and said so should you use fast money to
pay for it
no oh they're just saying like you can't
possibly be broke if you're if you can
afford doing a video like this but that
could be your friends Mercedes like
technology is so [ __ ] cheap now date
like you know like someone with a camera
yeah that knows how to edit yeah they
could do that [ __ ] dude her friend works
at the dress store someone's dad's
Mercedes they could park that in that's
a cheap B always wrong with that so do
what Jeff says reasoning what's their
actual reasoning so someone jokingly
said fast but looking at this like this
right and then fast but replied with a
little boy like drinking is like like I
see you kind of thing uh-huh
it was just a joke I was funny and so
people are uh they're like oh [ __ ] they
actually look at this [ __ ] so people
started giving this girl hate to like
you know you have all this money to
spend but then she was like you know
what I actually have a job I saved up to
pay for my dress she even get FAFSA so
people are saying cuz she's a senior you
know next year she's gonna go to college
so then that's what it's like what if
she doesn't even receive FAFSA but
people are assuming she gets fast
because she's black she's black she's
got black I don't know I saw some black
girls in the video she looks like a
messenger for sure yeah well I'm I think
it's difficult to see friend yeah your
prom dresses are so expensive yeah I
think got a prom but like I'm the prom
but alone and single
I want a problem with a date twice it
wasn't a bebe dress what a lot of prom
experience is you with the deep I don't
want to go to flow just seeing a problem
in junior prom oh it was great
you didn't go to the project we're
having a prime know when you said that I
got so excited why don't you go to prom
I didn't go because I was pregnant and I
didn't want to take my baby daddy
and I didn't I knew where we're gonna
have problems if I went either alone or
with girlfriend I'm like [ __ ] it I'm not
from only senior year yeah yeah you
could bring a freshman I was a senior I
was already pregnant but dude you could
have lived the Juneau dream that's a
[ __ ] rite of passage you know you
never saw those pictures of the ghetto
prom dresses were they there's like
pregnant and it literally like weeks
pregnant when I was still in high school
I wasn't sure you could have pulled it
off I could have but this is the thing I
wanted to have a great time you wanted a
drink I wanted a drink okay so I'm like
I can't move you ruined your prom dreams
girl I didn't drink my progress
hey prom and I don't even know what it
was I also wanted to go to my senior it
was the thing senior homecoming in your
ball the last day yeah senior yeah some
[ __ ] like that so for our for our high
school they would rent out all of
Disneyland and we would have a grad
night that was wait is it just one
school cuz I think grad night is a bunch
of different high schools it I wouldn't
know exciting go but I really wanted to
get I think go either I didn't go to
grad night
yes - he wouldn't like that the reason I
didn't go it was one no no no one I knew
was going but - it's an overnight thing
so it's like from five to five in the
morning and you're not allowed to leave
and girls have to wear heels what yeah
why yeah you have to wear like um a
formal attire you have to work he'll I
I don't know walking all fugly don't
have to wear uncomfortable shoes but
yeah you do like [ __ ] that and I'm doing
that you're greeting girls ready to be
hookers that's why I didn't go because
the chick I like - wasn't gonna go so I
didn't go for that reason I got asked to
prom and I was like no this is not dupit
oh you were a cool kid I was like $300
let's use that on E and go to a rig
that's tight
I got a boyfriend and my friend was
gonna go with his friend and then two
weeks before prom he dumped me Oh buddy
I want to spend money no he went with
his ex Oh for two weeks I like that tell
me who the [ __ ] is I'm a punch him in
the stomach
[ __ ] suddenly - apologized yeah
yeah cuz you got hot eight years later
yeah exactly yeah no but that night prom
night I was with my I was at my best
friend's house like helping her get
ready and then I didn't think I was
gonna care I thought like everything was
gonna be cool I'm like oh it's okay I'm
just not gonna go yeah but then seeing
her leave I started breaking down and
crying I'm like I should've gone to my
prom the foam oh yeah yeah you had a
foam oh we're gonna do prom at our house
and you'll have a blast yeah yeah I
really have a dress perfect we'll even
have all the songs and she's gonna get
fitted for tux and like proms I did I'm
doing a whole probably square
bridesmaids dress I'm gonna do a lemon
limo yeah I get to wear to go where am i
- that's not a progress a second wedding
and we'll do is we'll go eat beforehand
we'll go to like a shitty local
restaurant like a Chili's or something
prom dresses yep will order virgin
cocktails
cuz there's already teenagers and a
dress mom you gotta do it the time
they're doing and then we can wait as a
teenager like we're like worth part of
it and then they'll be like what da [ __ ]
like which one are you going to with
school yeah you know they probably would
look like we're in high school because
they look [ __ ] old enough that's true
they look like they're our age I mean
they don't but but but we like to think
they do excuse me it's okay especially
hey look they don't dress like boat dad
and I do so that's that's what's up held
back high school is where I go to hold
back held back for like in 30 years or
something I'm excited so how many
problems go to then and they held back
high school every year I never went to
one I love prom so much I stayed back
every year I don't want to have I want
to go to a ghetto prom where everyone
has matching Louie Vuitton print dresses
are you tired I've never seen that like
yeah yeah yeah like Louis Vuitton print
like we've Atomics dresses no they could
in like Hong Kong and China it's like
how they have a Louie Vuitton chair
that's like made from like old handbags
or like you know maybe the dresses have
like a leather stripe this silly yeah or
you could like match like Sadie Hawkins
but then it's like bizarre as hell like
I don't know like mercedes-benz print
clothes or something I don't know where
Sadie's Hawkins yeah Mercedes I don't
know I said prom dresses it's the best
[ __ ] in the world winter formal I almost
said Winterfell
I wanted to get me through the winter
one less no yeah I only went to winter
formal for freshman year and only I'm in
high school now I'm gonna go to every
single dance the only dance I want you
what happened to me cuz you got pregnant
at the end of high school I did go to
palm alone with my friend that you know
we both got dumped or I got dented and
she couldn't go with his four anymore
I did go with her and I basically spent
the whole night at the dessert table
eating his chocolate-covered
strawberries and then I asked [ __ ] yeah
it was really I asked for a box to go
why did you even go because I got
revenge hot so I could walk past my ex
and be like and it worked but then I
just heard that moment on yeah yeah yeah
and then I can then afterwards there was
no after-party I went to my friend
Tara's house and I ordered a pizza
because I had been starving myself for
two weeks on net just ate and cried oh
my god so you still love them because
you did all that work just just to get
back at him I didn't love him I was like
pissed that he dumped me for I don't
remember being that petty but I was
pretty petty you know what I kissed two
girls on prom night two different girls
girls my mom my sister so it's a party
kiss another one you mrs. Doubtfire that
should do ya like make out a like pet
cuz those are different one was make out
another one was yeah they're both make
out the trick is if you took two two
different girls but you didn't tell them
that you took that I think I ruined
myself because by 14 I was already
acting like a LA crackhead yeah that
sounds like it cuz you're like they're
all I did drugs it was like why do you
want to go to prom when there's already
raised to be with your friends but it's
expensive
yeah I mean like you're paying what 300
bucks or so who's paying 300 bucks for
dude no Sarge
Sarge pitching in Agito my mom's car I
do lemma yeah I took my car you might
have car tonight
yeah drove of my Celica I got my buddy
who is out of high school to [ __ ]
ride me in my date around it was pretty
sick
he was like the local guy where it's
like he's he's still high all the high
school kids I was like dude can you
drive us around be so sick and he's like
yeah sure
well my friend that I went was she
couldn't take her boyfriend because he
was over the age of being able to
legally be thinner
he was like 23 yeah he's gonna bring it
was part and prom like very drug or like
alcohol heavy for you know way after
prom yeah their prom party I didn't even
[ __ ] wrong dude what's the point I
try to I thought one year at prom and
then the next year when I was a senior I
didn't even [ __ ] that crazy when I was a
junior I [ __ ] her pal
didn't you lose your virginity and then
you gave up having sex for like two
years
yeah only cuz I had some thought really
guilty I had a bad sexual experience
because my like I lost my virginity to
x-men to accident yard in the movie
theater packed house yeah I was like
over in line yeah we're like sex men sex
man
[Music]